REACTIONS.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
FROM FOX NEWS WORLD HEADQUARTERS
IN NEW YORK.
ONE PERSON IS DEAD AND A LOT OF
TO A POLITICAL RETREAT HIT A
TRUCK ON THE RAILROAD TRACKS
NEAR THE WEST VIRGINIA BORDER,
THE VIRGINIA BORDER WITH
WEST VIRGINIA.
SEVERAL PEOPLE ON BOARD THE
TRAIN TAKEN TO HOSPITALS ARE
NATURALLY RIGHT AFTER IT
SOMETHING ELSE.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY HAS
THE LATEST FROM WHITE SULFUR
SPRINGS, WEST VIRGINIA.
>> GOOD EVENING.
CHARTERED TRAIN RIDE FROM
WASHINGTON, D.C., TO
WEST VIRGINIA TO COME WERE
ACCORDING TO ONE MEMBER.
THAT'S BECAUSE THEIR RIDE TO HER
RETREAT COLLIDED WITH THE
GARBAGE TRUCK ON THE TRACKS IN
THE TOWN OF CROZET.
WITHIN MINUTES, AS A STRONG
PLEADED WITH ANY PHYSICIANS ON
BOARD TO ADMINISTER FIRST AID TO
THE MOST SERIOUSLY INJURED.
THAT'S WHEN A HANDFUL OF
AMONG THE DOCTORS ON BOARD,
LOUISIANA SENATOR BILL CASSIDY,
OHIO CONGRESSMAN BRAD WEBSTER,
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL
BURGESS, TENNESSEE CONGRESSMAN
BILL ROWE, AND KANSAS
CONGRESSMAN ROGER MARSHALL WHO
TOLD US TO THE PASSENGERS IN THE
TRUCK REQUIRE THE MOST URGENT
ATTENTION.
ONE COULD NOT BE SAVED.
SPACE SO WE COULD NOT FIND A
PULSE.
HIS PUPILS WERE FIXED AND
DILATED.
THAT IT WAS BEST TO CALL THE
CODE AND MOVE OUR ATTENTION BACK
TO THE FIRST VICTIM.
>> FIVE TRAIN PASSENGERS WERE
INJURIES, INCLUDING A STAFFER
FOR HOUSE SPEAKER PAUL RYAN AND
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM MINNESOTA,
CONGRESSMAN JASON LEWIS, WHO WAS
EVALUATED FOR A CONCUSSION AND
TELLS FOX "I'M FINE COMPARED TO
TRAGICALLY THE TRUCK DRIVERS AND
THANKFUL FOR THE PROMPT ACTION
MY THOUGHTS ARE WITH THE FAMILY
GOING TO BE A WHILE UNTIL
AUTHORITIES KNOW HOW TRUCK AND
IT UP ON THE TRACKS IN FRONT OF
A HEAVILY GUARDED TRAIN.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A FULL
UNDERSTANDING YET AS TO WHAT
HAPPENED, BUT IT WAS A TRAIN
HITTING A TRUCK GOING AT A
THE BADLY DAMAGED ENGINE CAR WAS
EVENTUALLY REMOVED AND THE
REMAINING CARS WERE TOWED
BACKWARDS TO A TRAIN STATION IN
DOWNTOWN CHARLOTTESVILLE WHERE
REPUBLICANS WERE QUICKLY LOADED
ONTO BUSES FOR A DRIVE TO
THEIR RETREAT.
>> IT'S CERTAINLY A SOMBER MOOD.
THINKING ABOUT THOSE WHO WERE